>> PREVIOUSLY ON
>> AMERICAN'S NEXT TOP MODEL
>> JAEDA'S MAKEOVER LEFT HER
WITH LINGERING INSECURITIES.
>> (sobs)
I MISS MY OTHER HAIR,
AND NO MATTER HOW MUCH
I WANT IT BACK,
I'M NOT GONNA GET IT BACK.
>> AND MONIQUE LASHED OUT
AT MELROSE ONCE AGAIN.
>> SHE JUST WIPED SOMETHING
ON MY BED.
>> IT'S SO ICKY.
>> (laughing)
>> THEN WHEN AN ILLNESS
CAUSED MONIQUE
TO MISS HER PHOTO SHOOT...
>> CAN'T KEEP NOTHING DOWN.
>> HER PAST PERFORMANCE
WAS NOT STRONG ENOUGH
TO SAVE HER.
TEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> DO YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪
>> MONIQUE BATTLED ME
THE WHOLE TIME SHE WAS HERE.
>> SO--
>> LAST WEEK WHEN THEY WERE
CALLING THE LAST NAME
AND THEY CALLED HER NAME,
I WAS LIKE, BEFORE THEY CALLED
HER NAME, I'M LIKE,
I HOPE THEY CHOOSE MONIQUE.
>> MONIQUE'S PRETTY MUCH
THE ONLY ONE OUT OF ALL 13 GIRLS
THAT I DIDN'T LIKE.
AND, LIKE, LAST WEEK,
EVERYBODY KIND OF FELT
JUSTICE WAS SERVED.
>> THE HOUSE IS SO MUCH BETTER
WITHOUT MONIQUE.
I'M NOT SITTING THERE LIKE,
"WHAT IS SHE GONNA DO
TO ME NEXT?"
IT'S JUST... ALMOST A RELIEF.
IT IS A RELIEF.
>> GOOD-BYE!
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A PARTY
IN HERE.
ALL RIGHT. LET ME IN...
>> HOW MANY GIRLS CAN YOU FIT
IN THE DAMN SHOWER?
>> YEAH, I WANNA TRY.
>> WHOO!
>> (yelps)
>> WE ONLY HAVE THREE HOURS
TO SLEEP.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO GO...
>> CAN WE ALL JUST TRY
AND, LIKE, BE RESPECTFUL THAT
SOME PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO GET
THAT THREE HOURS OF SLEEP?
>> MELROSE FRUSTRATES ME
VERY MUCH,
AND I'M LIKE, DON'T COMPLAIN.
LIKE, THIS IS SUPPOSED
TO BE FUN.
I JUST WANNA ROCK 'N' ROLL
AND HAVE A GOOD TIME.
>> IT'S JUST, LIKE, ONE NIGHT
THAT I'M ASKING THAT
YOU GUYS JUST, LIKE,
TAKE IT DOWN A NOTCH, OKAY?
>> BITCH.
>> MELROSE ALWAYS RUBS GIRLS
THE WRONG WAY.
SHE'S A LITTLE MISS KNOW-IT-ALL.
♪♪
>> I HAVE PEOPLE LOOKING AT ME
LIKE THEY CAN'T--THEY'RE NOT
SURE EXACTLY WHAT I AM...
>> PLEASE.
>> IF I'M A BOY
THAT'S, LIKE, GIRLY,
OR IF I'M A GIRL THAT'SBOY-Y.
>> EVER SINCE I GOT MY HAIR CUT,
I'M SICK OF IT.
I JUST WANNA BE MY NORMAL SELF,
AND I'M NOT.
>> PEOPLE HAVE SEEN PEOPLE
WITH SHORT HAIR BEFORE.
YOU AIN'T THE ONLY ONE.
>> WELL, I FEEL LIKE,
AFTER BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
IT DOES MAKE MY CONFIDENCE
A LITTLE LOWER.
LIKE, ANYTHING I TRY,
I'M USUALLY GOOD AT IT,
AND... I REALLY DIDN'T REALIZE
WHAT MODELING IS.
>> YEAH.
>> I KNEW MODELING
WAS HARD WORK,
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW
IT WAS THIS HARD, YOU KNOW?
>> IT WAS, LIKE, HARD WORK.
>> IT'S SO FUNNY.
DO YOU WANT TO COME DOWN
TO EAT WITH US?
>> SURE. I JUST ATE, THOUGH.
I AM THE VOLUPTUOUS GIRL
IN THE HOUSE.
I DON'T HAVE THE FLAT STOMACH.
I DO HAVE LARGER BREASTS.
I HAVE HIPS.
I'M LEARNING TO LIVE WITH IT.
>> ANCHAL, ARE YOU COOKING
FOR A SMALL FAMILY?
>> THAT'S A LOT OF EGGS.
>> I'VE DEALT
WITH SO MANY ISSUES
THROUGHOUT MY CHILDHOOD.
I WAS REALLY UGLY.
I HAD BRACES, I HAD GLASSES.
I'M USED TO HEARING CRAP
ABOUT ME.
AND I'M--I TAKE IT IN
AND I DON'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
>> TYRA MAIL! COME ON!
TYRA MAIL.
"DON'T GET IT TWISTED.
FOR SOME OF YOU,
BEING A TOP MODEL
IS QUITE A STRETCH.
SO PROVE TO ME THAT
YOU WILL BEND OVER BACKWARDS
FOR FASHION."
>> OKAY.
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> OH!
>> YOGA!
>> WE'RE GONNA BE STRETCHED.
>> SO GET IT? TWISTED!
>> TWISTED!
♪♪
>> HI, GIRLS!
MY NAME IS STACEY McKENZIE,
AND I'M A MODEL,
AND I'M ALSO A JUDGE
FOR "CANADA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
SO TODAY I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A BIT OF IDEA ON HOW TO USE
YOUR EDGY QUIRKINESS
AND ALL OF THAT STUFF
TO, LIKE, USE THAT
INTO HIGH-FASHION POSING.
AND I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A TREAT FOR YOU GUYS.
ONE OF THE TOP,
TOP HIGH-FASHION POSERS
IN THE INDUSTRY.
>> LOOKS LIKE
WE GOT A GOOD GROUP TODAY.
>> (cheers and applause)
>> I'M JONATHAN NOSAN.
>> YEAH!
>> EXCITED TO WORK
WITH YOU TODAY.
AND WE'RE GONNA DO A LITTLE BIT
OF, UH, EXTREME EDITORIAL POSES.
KIND OF GOES LIKE THIS.
>> YEAH!
>> OH!
>> YOU HAVE TO DO SOME
OF THESE POSES FOR HIGH FASHION.
YOU MUST.
>> YEAH!
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> AAH!
>> HEY, I'M KIND
OF A FLEXIBLE PERSON,
BUT I CAN'T DO NONE OF THAT.
>> WHOA!
>> YEAH!
>> WHAT I DO IS EXTREME POSING.
SO I'LL TAKE A POSE AND DO
SOMETHING KIND OF LIKE THIS,
WHEREAS YOU MIGHT TAKE SOMETHING
AND TWIST IT
A LITTLE BIT LIKE THAT.
>> I'VE STARTED DOING YOGA,
AND I'M PRETTY CONFIDENT
IN THE FACT THAT
I'LL BE ABLE TO DO THIS GOOD
AND GET A GOOD POSE.
>> FIRST BASIC POSE
IS SOMETHING KIND OF LIKE THIS,
AND LIFTING IT UP.
>> A LOT OF PHOTOGRAPHERS,
A LOT OF CLIENTS,
THEY USE THIS POSE.
>> IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
JUST GONNA PUSH UP.
OPPOSITE HAND, GRAB.
BRING IT UP... UP...
>> ONE LEG UP.
>> IT HURTS SO GOOD!
>> BRING IT UP.
>> I WAS JUST LOOKING
AT EVERYBODY, JUST LIKE...
AND, LIKE, EVERYBODY'S
TRYING TO BE SERIOUS
YOU KNOW, THESE MODEL FACES.
IT CRACKED ME UP.
>> WHOO!
>> WELL, LIKE,
LIFT UP YOUR UPPER...
THAT'S NICE. YEAH, THAT'S NICE.
>> I DISCOVERED I WAS
MORE FLEXIBLE THAN I THOUGHT.
MY FEET WENT
FROM TOUCHING MY HEAD
TO BEING IN FRONT OF MY FACE.
MELROSE LOOKED AT ME LIKE,
"WHAT ARE YOU DOING?"
LIKE, "I'M SUPPOSED
TO HAVE THE SPOTLIGHT."
>> I THINK ANCHAL DOES GOOD
IN THE PERSPECTIVE
OF CONTORTING,
BUT I WOULD JUST HAVE TO SEE
WHAT A PICTURE WOULD LOOK LIKE.
>> VERY GOOD, ANCHAL.
>> ANCHAL'S A CONTORTIONIST,
ANYWAY.
>> YOU ARE.
>> WELL, I DIDN'T KNOW.
IT'S NOT THAT I DIDN'T THINK
YOU COULD DO IT.
I JUST DIDN'T KNOW.
>> WELL,
I SHOULD BURN SOMETHING.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO DO
CARDIO WORKOUT TO BURN FAT.
>> I DO. I USED TO GO RUNNING--
>> NO, YOU DON'T.
YOU'VE DONE IT ONCE
SINCE YOU'VE BEEN HERE.
>> I HAVEN'T DONE IT IN THE HOUSE.
>> WE'VE BEEN HERE FOUR WEEKS.
>> DOESN'T MEAN I DON'T DO IT.
>> ANCHAL EATS A LOT,
BUT DOESN'T DO A DAILY ROUTINE
TO BURN OFF WHAT SHE'S EATING.
I GUESS I JUST THOUGHT
TELLING HER
THE REALITY OF THE SITUATION
MIGHT HELP HER,
NOT THAT I SHOULD BE
EVEN TRYING TO HELP HER.
>> YOU DON'T SEE ME
EVERY MOMENT OF THE DAY.
I DON'T KNOW WHY MELROSE
HAS TO CONCERN HERSELF
WITH MY BODY.
IT'S MY BODY.
WHAT THE HELL DO YOU CARE?
♪♪
>> LIKE, ANCHAL'S CASE--
LIKE, HALF OF IT IS INSECURITY,
AND HALF OF IT IS
FISHING FOR COMPLIMENTS.
>> LIKE, 'CAUSE SOMETIMES
I FEEL LIKE SHE IS PUTTING
ON A BIG FAT FRONT.
WE CAN ALL USE REASSURANCE.
WE CAN ALL USE FRIENDS.
>> MELROSE--
SHE REALLY HAS GOOD INTENTIONS.
IF YOU REALLY LISTEN TO WHAT
SHE'S SAYING, YOU COULD USE IT
IN THIS COMPETITION.
>> I MEAN, I KNOW
IT'S NOT REALLY OUR BUSINESS--
>> I DIDN'T MEAN
TO HURT HER FEELINGS AT ALL.
I JUST OBVIOUSLY OFFENDED HER.
>> EUGENA SAID,
"SHE'S COMPETITION.
LEAVE HER ALONE. LET HER EAT.
LET HER NOT WORK OUT."
>> LET HER EAT
AND DO WHAT SHE WANTS.
>> WHATEVER.
>> I JUST THINK THAT
SHE'S TRYING TO GET A REACTION.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
LIKE, SHE IS SO BEAUTIFUL.
SHE DOES NOT EVEN REALIZE.
LIKE, THE FIRST TIME I SAW HER,
I WAS LIKE--
>> SHE KNOWS IT. I'M SORRY.
>> YEAH. NO, I THINK--
>> EVERY PERSON HERE
HAS BEEN LIKE, "YOU'RE THE MOST
GORGEOUS GIRL HERE,
YOU'RE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRL."
THE JUDGES HAVE TOLD HER
SHE'S THE MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY. NOW WORK WITH IT.
>> HONESTLY--HONESTLY--
>> I JUST--
I'M SICK OF HEARING IT.
>> WE'RE ALL SITTING
ON THE BALCONY,
AND ANCHAL OVERHEARS, YOU KNOW,
MELROSE TALKING SMACK ABOUT HER.
I THINK MELROSE
JUST GETS HER CONFIDENCE
BY PUTTING OTHER PEOPLE DOWN.
>> WELL, INITIALLY I THOUGHT
THAT SHE WAS ONE OF
THE STIFFEST COMPETITIONS HERE,
BUT AS THIS COMPETITION GOES ON,
SHE'S NOT BECOMING
MORE BEAUTIFUL TO ME.
>> YEAH.
>> THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY.
>> AND--AND AS I SEE HER
AND AS I SEE HER ATTITUDE
TOWARDS...
>> (crying)
IT JUST REALLY SUCKS
HOW MEAN THEY CAN BE.
I COME HERE AND I OPEN UP,
AND THEY'VE GIVEN ME
SOME STRENGTH.
AND THEY'RE THROWING IT
BACK AT ME LIKE IT--
>> GUESS WHAT?
GUESS WHAT, HONEY?
YOU KNOW WHY?
'CAUSE THEY'RE THE FAKE ONES.
>> (sobs)
♪♪
>> THEY'RE THE FAKE ONES.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> HONEY.
HONEY, THEY DON'T MATTER.
WE MATTER.
WE GOT YOUR BACK, HONEY.
>> (sniffles)
>> THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
>> I OVERHEARD MELROSE
TALKING ABOUT ME,
AND IT JUST KIND OF
REALLY FREAKING HURT ME.
>> INITIALLY I THOUGHT THAT
ANCHAL WAS THE ONE OF
THE STIFFEST COMPETITIONS HERE,
BUT AS THIS COMPETITION
GOES ON--
>> I REALLY THINK THAT SHE'S--
>> SHE'S NOT BECOMING
MORE BEAUTIFUL TO ME.
>> DON'T LISTEN TO THEM.
>> IT JUST HURTS SO... BAD.
>> I KNOW, GIRL.
I KNOW IT HURTS.
THEY DON'T MATTER, GIRL.
>> I HATE MELROSE,
AND IT TAKES EVERY OUNCE
OF STRENGTH IN MY BODY
NOT TO, UH, RETALIATE
WHEN SHE SAYS MEAN THINGS.
>> I REALLY DON'T HAVE
THAT CONFIDENCE IN ME.
I REALLY NEVER THINK
I'M BEAUTIFUL.
BUT I'M GOING TO DO THE BEST
I CAN.
>> WE ARE WHISKED AWAY TO DINNER
AT THE OASIS RESTAURANT.
>> WOW.
>> THERE'S A CHAIR
AND THERE'S A LITTLE PLACE CARD
THAT SAYS,
"RESERVED FOR A SPECIAL GUEST."
>> TO OUR UNKNOWN SPECIAL GUEST.
>> WHOEVER HE OR SHE MAY BE.
ALL THAT CONTORTIONISM
EARNED US A GOOD MEAL.
>> YES!
>> CAUGHT YOU!
>> WHOO!
>> TWIGGY WALKS IN THE DOOR,
AND I'M LIKE, "TWIGGY!"
>> SO I HAVE COME TO TALK
TO YOU GIRLIES ABOUT THE CHANGES
IN POSING IN MODELING.
>> SHE'S OUR JUDGE EVERY WEEK,
SO BEING ABLE
TO GO TO DINNER WITH HER
IN A LAID-BACK SITUATION
AND JUST TALK TO HER
LIKE A HUMAN BEING
INSTEAD OF A JUDGE
WAS SO RELAXING.
>> THAT'S WHY THIS BUSINESS
IS WONDERFUL,
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY SAY,
"THIS IS THE LOOK.
THIS IS HOW YOU'VE GOTTA BE."
BECAUSE MOST IMPORTANT
IS TO BE YOU
AND FIND YOUR OWN UNIQUENESS.
FIND--
DON'T TRY AND BE KATE MOSS.
DON'T TRY AND BE ERIN O'CONNOR.
I'M LOOKING FOR SOMEBODY NEW.
>> EVERY TIME MELROSE
WOULD LOOK AT TWIGGY,
SHE WOULD FREAK THE HELL OUT,
AND IT WAS SO FUNNY.
MELROSE WAS JUST LIKE...
"YEAH. YEAH."
TWIGGY'S ONE OF HER, LIKE,
ALL-TIME ICONS.
>> YOU HAVE AFFECTED, LIKE,
ALL OF OUR LIVES MORE THAN
I THINK YOU EVEN KNOW.
YOU DID CHANGE THE STANDARD
OF MODELING,
AND YOU DID CHANGE
THE WHOLE INDUSTRY.
>> I DIDN'T PLAN TO, BUT--
>> BUT YOU DID. THANK YOU!
MY DAD'S FROM ENGLAND.
HE'S FROM PORTSMOUTH.
>> OH IS HE?
>> YEAH, AND SO--
AND SO MY MOM AND DAD
LIVED IN ENGLAND
WHEN THEY FIRST GOT MARRIED...
>> MELROSE ALWAYS SUCKS UP
WHEN IT COMES TIME
TO, LIKE, MEETING PEOPLE,
WHICH IS A GOOD STRATEGY.
BUT IT'S KIND OF FUNNY
TO SEE HER STICK HER NOSE
RIGHT UP THEIR ASS.
>> SO I'LL SEE YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YEAH, CAN I HAVE A HUG?
>> BYE.
>> I WANT A HUG.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THIS IS SUCH
A DREAM COME TRUE FOR ME.
TWIGGY IS... HUGE.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL! TYRA MAIL!
>> "THERE'S SOME CATTY BITCHES
IN THE HOUSE."
>> MM-HMM.
>> "SHE'S EYEING YOU
AND READY TO KNOCK YOU OFF
YOUR PEDESTAL."
>> WHAT'S THAT SUPPOSED TO MEAN?
>> WE'RE GONNA BE
STANDING ON A PEDESTAL
TRYING TO FIGHT EACH OTHER OFF.
I GUARANTEE.
>> YOU BETTER WATCH YOURSELVES.
♪♪
>> HELLO, MY GORGEOUS LADIES.
I'M DESIGNER BAO TRANCHI,
AND I AM VERY WELL-KNOWN
FOR MY DECADENT COLLECTIONS.
TONIGHT, I AM HAVING
A HUGE, FANTASTIC EVENT,
AND IN ABOUT ONE HOUR,
ALL MY GUESTS
ARE GOING TO BE VIEWING
THE NEW BAO TRANCHI COLLECTION
ON ART INSTALLATIONS.
YOU WILL BE
MY ART INSTALLATIONS.
YESTERDAY, YOU LEARNED
COUTURE DRAMATIC POSES,
AND I WANT YOU TO CREATE
AN EVEN MORE EXTREME POSE
WHILE MAINTAINING
THE ELOQUENCE OF THE CLOTHES.
>> I DIDN'T DO WELL
WITH THE CONTORTIONIST DEAL.
I WAS JUST NOT REALLY GOOD
WITH THAT,
'CAUSE MY BODY'S NOT FLEXIBLE.
>> I HAVE BROUGHT
FAMED JEWELER ERICA COURTNEY.
>> (applause)
>> HI, HOW ARE YOU?
>> FANTASTIC. YOU LOOK GREAT.
>> HI, LADIES.
BEHIND ME ARE
TEN PIECES OF JEWELRY
WORTH $32,000.
YOU ALL GET TO PICK ONE ITEM
TO PAIR WITH BAO'S CREATIONS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO GO AND GET
AMAZINGLY BEAUTIFUL.
♪♪
>> TODAY'S CHALLENGE
IS ABOUT DOING OUR WHOLE
BODY CONTORTIONIST STUFF,
AND I'M SUPER EXCITED
TO GET OUT THERE AND PUMP IT,
BECAUSE I KNOW
I CAN DO THE BODY MOVES.
>> LIKE, YOU JUST NATURALLY KNOW
YOU'RE, LIKE, THE MOST AMAZING,
BEAUTIFUL THING IN THE WORLD.
AND, LIKE--
AND SHOW THAT IN YOUR BODY.
>> BAO SAYS SHE WANTS
THISFANTICIFULFAIRY
WHO'S REALLY NICE AND SWEET,
BUT ALSO, LIKE,
A COMPLETE DIVA BITCH.
I'M LIKE, "OKAY. I CAN DO THAT."
>> OKAY, GIRLS.
GET INTO YOUR FIRST POSE.
>> MY MUSCLES WERE LITERALLY
SHAKING LIKE A BOWL OF JELL-O.
BUT I KNEW I COULDN'T MOVE
BECAUSE I WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE A STATUE.
>> IT'S ABOUT REALLY
JUST STEPPING OUT OF THE BOX
AND CONTORTING YOURSELF
INTO DIFFERENT POSITIONS.
MORE LIKE ART
INSTEAD OF, YOU KNOW,
THE STEREOTYPICAL MODEL.
>> JUST AS SOON AS I GOT THERE,
I JUST STARTED TO GO WITH IT.
SO I'M TRYING TO DO
A LOT OF POSES
THAT COMPLEMENTS MY BODY SHAPE.
>> I THOUGHT THAT EUGENA
WAS VERY INSPIRING.
PEOPLE IN THE AUDIENCE
LOVED HER.
>> I THINK THIS IS A CHALLENGE
THAT I CAN WIN
BECAUSE I'M CONFIDENT
THAT I CAN HIT A POSE,
LOOK HIGH-FASHION
AND BE ARTISTIC WITH IT.
>> GIVEN THAT JAEDA
HAS A VERY STRONG BUILD,
I THINK SHE COULD HAVE SOFTENED
HER FACE A LITTLE BIT.
>> IT WAS REALLY INTENSE.
I WAS KIND OF PLAYING IT SAFE
BECAUSE I WASN'T
ABOUT TO LIFT UP MY LEG
AND STAND ON ONE LEG
AND THEN FALL OFF.
>> OKAY, LADIES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YOU GUYS LOOK AMAZING.
>> IT WAS SUPER HARD
TO CHOOSE A WINNER.
I THINK THAT
THE GIRL WHO DESERVES
TO BE PUT ON A PEDESTAL...
WAS EUGENA.
SO PLEASE GO ON THE PEDESTAL.
>> DAMN. (laughs)
>> AND ALL THE JEWELRY
THAT YOU GIRLS HAD PICKED
FROM ERICA COURTNEY TODAY,
EUGENA WILL OWN ALL THE JEWELRY
AS THE PRIZE FOR WINNING.
>> AAH!
>> $32,000 WORTH OF JEWELRY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
I DIDN'T HAVE ANY JEWELRY
WHEN I CAME HERE,
BECAUSE IN PALMDALE
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANY EXPENSIVE JEWELERS
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
NOW I GOT $32,000 WORTH.
>> I JUST WISH I WOULD'VE HAD
A LITTLE BIT MORE SMILE,
'CAUSE I WAS CONCENTRATING
SO HARD I KNOW I WAS LIKE...
WHEN I SHOULD HAVE BEEN LIKE...
>> I DIDN'T SMILE AT ALL.
>> YOU CAN'T BE UP THERE
AND BE LIKE--
>> NO, NOT SMILING, BUT LIKE--
THERE'S--THIS IS A VERY--
THESE ARE
TWO VERY DIFFERENT FACES.
THIS...
AND THIS...
DO YOU SEE HOW DIFFERENT
THEY ARE?
LIKE, JUST WHEN YOU HAVE
A LITTLE BIT OF HAPPINESS
IN THERE, IT'LL SELL AN OUTFIT.
I JUST FEEL LIKE THIS OUTFIT,
WHEN I SAW IT, WAS SO ME.
AND THEN, THE WAY THAT
THEY DID THE HAIR...
>> MELROSE...
(sigh) OH, MAN.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
SHE'S JUST--
SHE GETS TO THAT POINT IN ME,
LIKE, WHERE I'M JUST LIKE,
"OH, SHUT UP!"
>> I'M JUST THINKING ABOUT
WHAT I CAN DO NEXT TIME
TO IMPROVE MYSELF.
>> MELROSE...
SHE JUST LIKES TO TALK.
TALK, TALK, TALK, TALK, TALK.
(whispering) AND I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY REALLY LIKES
TO HEAR HER VOICE.
I THINK A LOT OF US WOULD
JUST LIKE TO HAVE MELROSE GONE.
♪♪
>> YAY!
>> AAH!
(applause)
>> I'M HAPPY TO SEE
NICE, BRIGHT, CHEERFUL FACES,
BUT I KNOW THAT EVERYBODY
IS SMILING AND CHEERFUL
BECAUSE I WALKED IN HERE NOW.
BUT I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ALL
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT IS DEEPER.
AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS A--IS A SUBJECT
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO ME,
AND IT'S FEAR.
BECAUSE I FEEL THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE,
INCLUDING MYSELF,
CAN SOMETIMES
BE LED BY OUR FEAR.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT
HAS MADE YOU FEEL INSECURE
AND IN SOME WAY
INSTILLED A FEAR INSIDE OF YOU?
>> UH, JUST THE OLD THING.
IT IS KIND OF A FEAR,
'CAUSE I'M 23,
AND I'VE PUT IT OFF
TO GO TO SCHOOL
AND GET MY DEGREE AND--
>> ISN'T THAT CRAZY?
"I'M 23, AND I'M OLD."
>> (laughing)
>> THAT'S THE SICK,
CRAZY FASHION INDUSTRY.
THAT IS A FEAR.
IT'S SUCH A TICKING TIME CLOCK,
AND "I HAVE TO GET IT NOW!
AND I HAVE TO GET IT NOW!
I'M GONNA BE TOO OLD.
I'M GONNA HAVE TO RETIRE
WHEN I'M 28, 'CAUSE THAT MEANS
I'M A SENIOR CITIZEN."
ANYBODY ELSE?
>> LIKE, WITH THE HAIR THING--
LIKE, MAKING SURE THAT
I SHOW CONFIDENCE WITH MY HAIR.
'CAUSE IT VARIES, DAY TO DAY.
LIKE, SOMETIMES I'LL BE LIKE,
BOOM, MAN. I LOOK HOT!
YOU KNOW?
AND THERE'S OTHER DAYS,
I'M LIKE,
OH, I WISH I HAD MY HAIR.
>> I LOVE PUTTING SHORT HAIR
ON GIRLS THAT HAVE STRONG FACES,
BECAUSE THEN YOU CAN SEE
THEIR BONE STRUCTURE.
AND IT'S A COMPLIMENT TO YOU
THAT I SAW SOMETHING IN YOU
THAT MEANT THAT
YOU CAN HANDLE THAT.
>> TYRA, SHE REALLY THINKS
THAT I CAN BE A MODEL,
AND I CAN DO THIS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
SOMETIMES I LOOK AROUND
AT ALL THE GIRLS,
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE
I COULD GO HOME TOMORROW.
>> IS ANYBODY STRUGGLING WITH
THE INTERPERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN THE GIRLS?
>> (laughing)
>> THERE'S LAUGHING, MELROSE.
WHAT'S UP?
>> I JUST--
I THINK THAT WE EACH FIND
DIFFERENT THINGS IN EACH OTHER
THAT WE CAN RELATE TO,
AND THAT HELP US STRONGER
IN THIS COMPETITION.
NOT LET THINGS
THAT DON'T MATTER AFFECT US,
'CAUSE THERE ARE THINGS
IN EVERYDAY LIFE
THAT GO ON OUTSIDE OF THIS HOUSE
THAT WE STILL
HAVE TO WORK THROUGH.
>> WHAT TYPE OF THINGS
ARE YOU WORKING THROUGH?
>> JUST THAT...
YOU KNOW, PATIENCE,
THINK BEFORE YOU TALK.
>> SO YOU SAY THINGS
THAT MIGHT HURT
OTHER PEOPLE'S FEELINGS, OR...
>> YEAH. AND IT'S, LIKE,
JUST MAYBE IT'S GOING ON
IN MY HEAD, LIKE--
>> HAS ANYBODY BEEN HURT BY
SOMETHING THAT MELROSE HAS SAID?
>> UM, I OVERHEARD THEM TALKING,
AND HERE I GO AGAIN.
>> ANCHAL...
>> NO, SAY IT.
>> IT WAS A HURTFUL THING.
>> NO, LET--LET HER TALK.
LET HER TALK.
>> IT WAS JUST REALLY HARD
TO HEAR IT.
I OVERHEARD THEM
TALKING IN THE JACUZZI.
I JUST STARTING SAYING STUFF
TO MYSELF LIKE,
"IT'S OKAY. LET IT GO."
AND I HEAR PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT ME IN THE HOUSE.
>> YOU TAKE IT IN,
AND YOU IGNORE IT.
BUT YOU SEE,
YOU STORE IT INSIDE,
AND IT EATS YOU UP.
>> I NEVER REALLY HAD FRIENDS.
I ALWAYS GOT MADE FUN OF.
AND NOBODY BELIEVES THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY I LOOK NOW.
BUT IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO BELIEVE IN MYSELF.
I JUST NEVER HAD
THAT SELF-CONFIDENCE.
>> YOU DON'T STAND UP
FOR YOURSELF,
AND YOU INTERNALIZE IT
AND START TAKING IT OUT
ON YOURSELF.
I DO THE SAME THING.
I'M THE LEAST CONFRONTATIONAL
PERSON IN THE WORLD.
>> ANCHAL'S BEING SO FAKE,
BECAUSE SHE SITS HERE
AND HAS NO CONFIDENCE.
SHE KNOWS SHE'S PRETTY.
>> WELL, I WAS IN A SITUATION
WITH A MODEL THAT WAS
AN AWFUL SITUATION FOR ME.
I COULDN'T STAND UP FOR MYSELF.
I WAS INTIMIDATED BY HER.
I WAS TERRIFIED OF HER.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO STAND UP FOR YOURSELVES,
BECAUSE THIS INDUSTRY
IS A DOG-EAT-DOG INDUSTRY.
AND ALL OF YOU ARE COMPETING
FOR ONE PRIZE,
AND YOU CANNOT LET
THAT GIRL GET IN YOUR HEAD
AND TRY TO THROW YOU OFF BASE.
ALL RIGHT?
ALL RIGHT, I LOVE ALL Y'ALL.
GIVE ME A HUG.
>> WE LOVE YOU, TOO.
>> GIVE ME A HUG.
>> I HOPE AND PRAY
THAT TYRA DOESN'T SEE ME
AS THIS HORRIFYING PERSON.
BUT I DO FEEL KIND OF
SINGLED OUT IN THE GROUP
AS, LIKE, THE MEAN ONE.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> WHOO!
>> COME ON, GUYS.
ALL RIGHT, HOMEYS.
"MODELS AREN'T NECESSARILY
THE MOST BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
IN THE WORLD.
THEY TEND TO BE GAWKY,
HAVE EYES THAT ARE
TOO FAR APART
AND FOREHEADS THAT ARE TOO BIG.
THEY PRETTY MUCH
ARE FREAKS OF NATURE.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OOH.
>> WEIRDOS!
♪♪
>> WE ARE
IN THE MIDDLE OF NOWHERE,
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DESERT,
ABOUT TWO HOURS
AWAY FROM OUR HOUSE.
>> GOOD MORNING,
AND WELCOME TO THE CIRCUS!
>> AAH! YAY!
>> YOU'RE GOING TO DO A SHOOT
THAT IS BASED ON
THE FREAK SHOW CIRCUSES
AT THE TURN OF THE CENTURY.
THIS SHOOT IS GONNA BE
VERY, VERY DARK AND MOODY AND...
YOU KNOW THE JUDGES ARE LOOKING
FOR HOW YOU CAN ADAPT
IN SITUATIONS LIKE THIS
AND REALLY PERFORM.
ALL RIGHT?
I'M GONNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER--
MIKE ROSENTHAL.
HERE HE IS.
>> HEY! HI!
>> MIKE'S A VERY TALENTED
PHOTOGRAPHER,
AND YOU MAY RECOGNIZE HIM FROM
SOME OF OUR PAST PHOTO SHOOTS.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO
REALLY EMBRACE THE CHARACTERS
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE YOU GIRLS.
MEGG, YOU ARE GONNA BE
THE BEARDED LADY...
>> (laughing)
>> JAEDA, THE STRONG WOMAN.
>> A.J., THE CANNIBAL.
>> YES! YES!
>> ANCHAL, THE GIANT LADY.
>> CARIDEE...
>> YOU'RE GONNA BE
THE ELEPHANT WOMAN.
>> OOH!
>> EUGENA, GET READY FOR A BEAK,
'CAUSE YOU'RE GONNA BE
THE BIRD LADY.
BROOKE, THE RUBBER GIRL.
MELROSE...
NOW WHAT DO WE DO
WITH LITTLE MELROSE?
WE DECIDED WE'RE GONNA KEEP
YOUR BODY THE WAY IT IS,
WORK IT OUT,
BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE YOUR FACE
LIKE A OLD LADY, HONEY.
>> OOH.
>> SO YOU'RE GONNA BE
THE WOMAN WITH THE OLD FACE,
BUT THE YOUNG BODY.
NOW WHO DO I HAVE LEFT?
>> ARE WE GONNA BE
SIAMESE TWINS?
>> OH, WE'RE SIAMESE TWINS.
>> OF COURSE YOU'RE
SIAMESE TWINS!
>> YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA BE
SIAMESE TWINS.
>> THAT'S AWESOME.
>> YOU'LL SEE THE HAIR
AND MAKEUP TRAILERS OVER THERE,
AND I'M GONNA COME
JOIN YOU OVER THERE
>> SEXY.
>> AT LEAST THIS WAY
SHE CAN GET, LIKE,
A CUTE PROFILE.
>> (imitates trumpeting)
>> GIRLS!
TALK TO ME FOR A SEC.
EVERYBODY COME OUTSIDE.
>> SO WE'VE GOT
A SPECIAL GUEST TODAY.
>> HEY, YOU GUYS.
>> MY NAME IS ATOOSA RUBENSTEIN.
I'M THE EDITOR IN CHIEF
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE.
I'M REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE SO MANY
TOP, TOP MODELS' CAREERS
WERE LAUNCHED AT "SEVENTEEN."
I REALLY WANTED TO SEE
YOU GUYS IN ACTION
BECAUSE ONE OF YOU
IS GONNA BE ON MY COVER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO, A.J., YOU'RE ALMOST DONE.
SO WE'RE GONNA START
BY SHOOTING YOU TODAY.
>> OH, YOU'LL GET EATEN
AND LOVE IT.
>> SO I WANT YOU
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
I WANT IT TO BE SENSUAL
FOR SURE.
BUT YOU'RE HUNGRY, REMEMBER.
YOU'RE MORE OF A CANNIBAL.
SO I WANT, LIKE,
A DARK SIDE TO THIS.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> I'M IN THIS METAL CAGE
WITH JUST BLOOD AND RAW MEAT
IN THERE.
IT'S A LITTLE SICK AND TWISTED,
WHICH IS KIND OF LIKE ME.
>> OKAY, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE GETTING READY
TO SIT DOWN ON THE TOILET.
>> (laughs)
>> 'CAUSE RUBBER GIRL
IS A LITTLE MORE ELONGATED.
>> LIKE YOU KNOW
THOSE PEOPLE WHO DO YOGA?
THEY'RE SO ELEGANT.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> FOREHEADS HAVE TO TOUCH.
>> OH, YOU WANT IT TO BE CLOSE.
>> IT MEANS SO IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU GUYS ARE JOINED BY--
>> IN THE HEAD.
>> IN THE HEAD, EXACTLY.
>> NICE AND STRAIGHT.
>> ...CREATIVELY.
>> IS THIS THE FIRST TIME
YOU'RE SHOOTING THEM TOGETHER?
>> YES, ACTUALLY.
SO WHAT'S INTERESTING...
>> YOU'RE USED TO BEING TOGETHER
ALL THE TIME.
>> THE TWINS STARTED OFF
A LITTLE AWKWARD,
BUT THEY ENDED UP
EMBRACING ONE ANOTHER
AND GETTING MORE INTERTWINED,
AND IT BECAME MUCH MORE
INTERESTING AND COMPLEX.
>> I'M LOOKING AT MYSELF LIKE,
"HI. YOU LOOK REALLY UGLY."
I KNOW THAT I HAVE
TO GO OUT THERE AND ROCK IT.
>> EW, IT SMELLS.
DID YOU REALLY HAVE TO PAINT IT?
>> (laughs)
>> (European accent) GOT TO TALK
LIKE THEES NOW.
IT WAS SO FUNNY,
'CAUSE, DUDE, I HAVE A BEARD.
I MEAN, I'D NEVER SEEN MYSELF
WITH A BEARD BEFORE.
>> NOW I DON'T WANT
TO OVER-DIRECT YOU.
I WANT YOU TO GIVE ME
MEGG FROM CASTING,
THE NUDE SHOOT.
'CAUSE YOU WERE SO NATURAL
AND EFFORTLESS.
>> IT'S A LITTLE POSE-Y.
SO IF YOU ARE GONNA MOVE,
YOU KNOW, DO SOMETHING
THAT WOULD FEEL REALLY ORGANIC.
>> MEGG, AGAIN--
HUGE DISAPPOINTMENT.
WHEN YOU TALK TO MEGG,
HER WHOLE FACE LIGHTS UP.
BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
SHE CAN BE A SUCCESSFUL MODEL.
WHAT WAS IT THAT
IN THE BEGINNING
WAS JUST EFFORTLESS?
>> THAT--I WASN'T EVEN THINKING.
I JUST WENT UP THERE.
I DIDN'T HAVE A MIND.
>> THAT'S A GOOD ANSWER.
>> WHEN I THINK TOO MUCH,
IT'S JUST--IT'S ALL OVER FOR ME.
I'M LIKE A CRASHING AIRPLANE.
LIKE, I REALLY WANT TO TAKE
THIS OFF, LIKE, RIGHT NOW.
LIKE, I JUST, LIKE,
I CAN DO SO MUCH BETTER,
AND, LIKE, I'M TOO WORRIED
ABOUT HAVING, LIKE, TO GET A--
(sniffles) BE PERFECT AT IT.
IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
LIKE, I REALLY WANT TO STOP,
BECAUSE I KNOW I HAVE, LIKE,
SUCH GOOD POTENTIAL
TO BE A GOOD MODEL, YOU KNOW?
>> YOU DO.
>> JUST THINK POSITIVE.
>> ALL SET.
>> WE GOOD?
OKAY.
(shutter clicks)
>> EXCELLENT.
♪♪
>> I ALMOST DIDN'T EVEN NOTICE
YOU HAD A SNOUT.
>> (laughs) OH, REALLY?
>> SERIOUSLY.
>> 'CAUSE YOU WERE SO FIERCE.
>> REALLY STRONG.
♪♪
>> BIRD WOMAN.
OOH, I ACTUALLY LIKE THAT.
THAT'S CUTE.
I LOVE THE LITTLE SMIRK.
♪♪
>> ANCHAL?
>> YES?
>> THIS IS NOT PRETTY.
DOES THAT LOOK PRETTY?
>> NO.
>> DOES THIS LOOK PRETTIER?
>> I WAS FREAKING OUT,
SO I WAS LIKE, "ANCHAL,
IF YOU DON'T DO THIS RIGHT,
YOU'RE NOT GONNA MAKE IT."
>> I ALWAYS FEEL LIKE
THE BEST PICTURES
AND THE MOST BEAUTIFUL
FASHION PICTURES
IS WHERE THAT--THERE'S, LIKE,
A REAL THING HAPPENING, YEAH.
SO, LIKE, GET TO THAT PLACE,
AND SEE--SEE WHAT YOU CAN DO.
>> LOOK HOW GREAT THIS IS.
THIS IS SO MUCH BETTER FOR HER.
THIS IS THE MOST CREATIVE
I HAVE EVER SEEN YOU, ANCHAL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU READY TO BE THE STRONG WOMAN?
>> YES.
>> I LOVE THE CONTOURED ABS.
HEY, JAEDA, IN THE HOUSE,
IN THE POOL ROOM--
WHAT'S THE PICTURE OF TYRA
ON THE WALL?
GIVE ME SOME
OF TYRA IN THAT PICTURE.
(grunts)
>> (grunts)
>> YOU GOTTA MAKE SOME NOISE.
EITHER DO IT AND COMMIT TO IT,
OR DON'T.
>> (grunts)
>> JAEDA, IF WE CAN
SPEND LESS TIME TRYING
TO PULL YOU OUT OF YOUR SHELL,
THEN WE CAN
SPEND MORE TIME FOCUSING
ON MAKING THE SHOT AMAZING.
>> I LIKE YOUR VARIETY, MELROSE.
KEEP IT UP.
OH, I LOVE THIS ONE.
>> ALL RIGHT,
THIS IS THE LAST ONE.
THERE YOU GO.
EXCELLENT.
>> MELROSE,
GET YOUR ASS OVER HERE.
>> MELROSE DID A PHENOMENAL JOB.
SHE HAD AN UGLY FACE,
BUT YET SHE JUST LEANED INTO IT,
AND SHE JUST... SHE JUST HIT IT
OUT OF THE BALLPARK.
>> MY GOD,
THAT'S A WRAP FOR THE DAY.
MY LORD.
♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> TYRA MAIL.
>> LET'S MAKE IT QUICK.
AMANDA'S BLADDER
CAN'T HANDLE TOO MUCH.
>> THIS IS FOR REAL.
>> NO FAIR LAUGHING.
>> "TOMORROW,
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY NINE WILL CONTINUE ON
HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I-I HAVE AN INTENSE FEELING
THAT I'M GONNA BE, LIKE,
OFF TOMORROW.
LIKE, ELIMINATED.
>> I WOULD HATE
TO SEE ANYBODY GO, YOU KNOW?
>> I'M NOT OVER THE COMPETITION.
I'M OVER, LIKE,
THE PEOPLE, AND, LIKE--
I THINK IT KINDA OF, LIKE,
TRASHES MY--MY SOUL, LIKE,
AND I DON'T LIKE THAT.
AS MUCH AS SOME OF THE GIRLS,
THEY REALLY BOTHER ME
AND ANNOY ME,
I DON'T WANT TO GO HOME,
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
I HAVE A GOOD CHANCE HERE.
>> I AM FEELING PRETTY GOOD
ABOUT MY PERFORMANCE.
BUT THEN AGAIN,
EVERYBODY IN THE HOUSE RIGHT NOW
TAKES REALLY GOOD PHOTOS.
IT'S GOING TO BE
A HARD, HARD JUDGING PANEL.
>> MY THOUGHTS
ON THE COMPETITION
REALLY CHANGED.
LIKE, I DON'T KNOW.
I COULD GO HOME TOMORROW,
AND I-I KIND OF FEEL LIKE
I AM GOING TO.
♪♪
>> I HAVE GOTTA SAY,
THIS MIGHT BE THE FIRST TIME
THEY ALL ARE DRESSED
LIKE REAL MODELS...
>> I COULDN'T AGREE MORE,
EVERY ONE OF THEM.
>> EVERYBODY.
WELL, WELCOME BACK
TO THE JUDGING ROOM.
IT'S TIME TO MAKE ANOTHER CUT.
YOU KNOW ABOUT
OUR FABULOUS PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT WITH
ONE OF THE TOP MODEL AGENCIES
IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT.
THE NEXT IS A 6-PAGE SPREAD,
AND ON TOP OF THAT,
A COVER OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES--
THE LOVELY NIGEL BARKER...
>> HEY, LADIES.
>> MISS J. ALEXANDER.
LOVELY, LOVELY...
FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND TWIGGY...
>> HELLO.
>> AND I'M VERY PROUD
TO INTRODUCE A WOMAN
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY MET,
BUT A WOMAN THAT
I KNOW AND RESPECT--
ATOOSA RUBENSTEIN.
SHE IS THE EDITOR IN CHIEF
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
SO SHE THE HEAD HONCHO,
THE GURU BEHIND THE MAGAZINE.
SO THIS WEEK,
YOU LEARNED ALL ABOUT POSING--
EDITORIAL POSING--
AND YOU LEARNED
ALL KIND OF WEIRD... POSES,
AND HOW TO ISOLATE
CERTAIN MUSCLES.
TO PLAY ON THAT,
I DECIDED THAT I WANTED YOU ALL
TO DO A FASHION SHOOT
IN A FREAK CIRCUS FORMAT.
AND, A.J., YOU ARE FIRST
IN THE EVALUATIONS TONIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, A.J.,
SO WHAT CIRCUS FREAK WERE YOU?
>> I WAS A CANNIBAL.
>> ALL RIGHT,
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
WOW, A.J.,
THAT LOOKS REALLY STRONG.
LOOK AT YOUR BODY LANGUAGE.
>> WOW.
>> AMAZING.
THAT STRANGE SHAPE
ALL CONTORTED, BUT I LOVE IT.
IT LOOKS GREAT,
IT LOOKS FASHIONY.
>> A.J.,
DO YOU SEE YOUR LEFT HAND,
HOW MUCH ENERGY IS IN YOUR HAND?
WE SAY THIS ALL THE TIME--
THAT YOU'RE MODELING
FROM THE TIP OF YOUR HEAD
TO YOUR TOES TO YOUR HANDS.
>> AND THE INTENSITY
IN YOUR EYES,
AND IT LEAPS OFF THE PAGE,
SO THAT'S WHY I LOVE IT.
>> ALL RIGHT, A.J., THANK YOU.
EUGENA.
SO, EUGENA,
YOU HAD TO POSE THIS WEEK
ON A PEDESTAL,
AND, GIRL, I HEARD YOU WERE
FIERCE UP THERE,
AND YOU WERE
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
>> (chuckles)
>> WHAT CIRCUS FREAK WERE YOU?
>> A BIRD WOMAN.
>> (imitates chicken clucking)
>> (laughter)
>> EUGENA,
I THINK FOR THE FIRST TIME,
THIS IS THE BEST EYE CONTACT
I'VE SEEN WITH YOU IN A SHOT.
>> WE WANNA BUY
THE FEATHERS AND THE NOSE,
BECAUSE I GUESS THAT'S
THE NEW LOOK FOR THE SEASON.
THE FASHION INDUSTRY
AND MODELING AND ALL THAT--
IT'S JUST BRAINWASHING PEOPLE
TO THINK SOMETHING'S FABULOUS.
>> YEAH.
>> AND, EUGENA,
DRESSED LIKE THAT
AND LOOKING LIKE THAT
AND SMILING LIKE YOU ARE
RIGHT NOW,
I'D BOOK YOU FOR A JOB.
>> IT'S CRAZY THAT
YOU HAD TO PUT ON A NOSE
AND SOME CRAZY FEATHERS
AND GET IN A CAGE...
>> YEAH.
>> TO PUSH THROUGH.
UP NEXT IS BROOKE.
AND WHO WERE YOU?
>> I WAS RUBBER GIRL.
>> FROM THE PHOTOGRAPH,
YOU ACTUALLY WOULDN'T KNOW
HOW TALL YOU WERE.
YOU'VE GOT--YOUR LEGS
ARE IN LOVELY PROPORTION
TO YOUR BODY.
I ACTUALLY LOVE
THE BODY LANGUAGE
IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
IT'S THE FACE THAT LET ME DOWN
A LITTLE BIT.
>> I AGREE.
>> IT'S LIKE A CLASSIC
FREAK SHOW SHOT.
>> I LIKE THIS PICTURE, BROOKE.
I THINK IT'S KIND OF HAUNTING.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T THINK
EVERYTHING HAS TO BE, LIKE...
(growls)
>> (laughs)
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
>> THE NEXT CIRCUS FREAK
THAT I'M GONNA CALL--
THE SIAMESE TWINS.
(drumroll)
>> SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> OOH... CHILD.
MMM!
JUST A BUNCH OF FREAKS.
>> I LOVE IT.
UM, UH, THE PHOTOGRAPH'S
WONDERFUL.
YOU'RE--THE--THE FOUR LEGS
ARE--ARE DIVINE, AREN'T THEY?
>> THAT'S WHAT I MEANT.
>> AMANDA, YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT.
I FEEL LIKE
HOW THE LIGHT IS HITTING
THE BOTTOM OF YOUR FACE
IS MAKING
YOUR CHIN AND MOUTH AREA
LOOK A LITTLE SWOLLEN.
DO YOU SEE THAT?
AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT YOU ONLY LEARN
BY MODELING MORE,
SO THAT THE LIGHT'S
NOT HITTING YOU IN A WEIRD WAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
>> UP NEXT IS ANCHAL.
>> I WAS A GIANT.
>> WELL,
LET'S SEE HOW YOU LOOKED
WITH YOUR BIG SELF.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT
THE FUNNY THING IS?
IS--IS AS A SHOT,
I THINK YOU LOOK
REALLY BEAUTIFUL.
BUT AS A GIANT, YOU LOOK TINY.
>> YOU SHOULD'VE BEEN THINKING,
"FEE-FIE-FO-FUM!"
>> REGARDLESS OF ALL THAT,
REALLY A--
REALLY A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE.
>> THE THING THAT
I WOULD'VE DONE--
BEING THE GIANT LADY--
IS I WOULD'VE BROUGHT MYSELF
TOWARDS THE CAMERA.
THAT WAY, THE TABLE
WOULD'VE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER BACK AND SMALLER,
AND THE LAMP AS WELL.
>> JAEDA?
>> I WAS THE STRONG WOMAN.
>> YOU'RE KIND OF SNARLING.
I LO--I ACTUALLY LOVE IT.
>> WE FOUND ON THE SET--
>> YOUR PHOTO IS EXTRAORDINARY.
>> ON THE SET,
JAEDA WAS JUST STOPPING
JUST SHORT OF REALLY
PUTTING IT OUT THERE...
>> YEAH.
>> AND BEING FEROCIOUS.
I MEAN, THE PROBLEM WAS THAT
JAY HAD TO SPEND SO MUCH TIME
COACHING YOU THAT HE WASN'T
ABLE TO DIRECT, YOU KNOW?
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IF THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
IS SPENDING THAT MUCH TIME
TRYING TO GET SOMETHING
OUT OF YOU,
IT'S GONNA STOP THE PICTURE
FROM BEING AS GREAT
AS IT CAN BE.
>> I WOULD RATHER HAVE SEEN YOU
BE A STRONG WOMAN
THAT'S JUST ALOOF, LIKE,
"THIS WEIGHS A MILLION POUNDS,
AND LOOK HOW STRONG I AM"...
>> MM-HMM.
>> THAN DOING THAT HALF FACE.
LIKE, IT LOOKS LIKE BAD ACTING.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, JAEDA.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT IS MELROSE.
AND WHAT FREAK WERE YOU?
>> I WAS THE OLD FACE
WITH THE HOT YOUNG BODY.
>> OH!
>> REALLY UGLY.
>> (laughter)
>> REALLY UGLY FACE.
>> I-I WOULDN'T SAY IT'S UGLY.
I THINK IT'S JUST AGE.
BUT WHAT I LOVE ABOUT IT
IS YOU'RE STILL LIKE,
"I'M WRINKLED, BUT I'M SO HOT."
>> (laughter)
>> CAN WE SEE THE OLD FACE?
>> OOH!
>> OOH.
>> (chuckles) EW, SO UGLY!
>> THERE'S SOMETHING
EXTREMELY DISTURBING
ABOUT THIS PICTURE.
>> I KNOW.
>> (laughter)
>> PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE I LIKE IT.
>> UP NEXT IS MEGG.
>> I WAS THE BEARDED LADY.
IT WAS FUNNY.
>> (laughter)
>> ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S
CHECK YOUR HAIRY FACE OUT.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE WAITING
TO START YOUR SESSION
OF PHOTOGRAPHY.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE FACE
AND THE BEARD, IT'S--
THE WHOLE BODY LANGUAGE IS--
>> WHAT'S WRONG, MEGG?
BECAUSE YOU SEEM
A LITTLE DOWN RIGHT NOW.
>> (sighs)
>> WHAT'S THE MATTER?
>> I'M SO WORRIED ABOUT...
WHAT I LOOK LIKE IN MY PICTURES
THAT IT COMES OUT IN MY PHOTOS.
THAT IT DOESN'T--
IT'S NOT ALL THAT I CAN GIVE,
AND I KNOW I'M CAPABLE OF GIVING
SO MUCH MORE THAN THAT PHOTO,
AND IT'S JUST--
IT'S, LIKE, SERIOUSLY,
A DISAPPOINTMENT
TO LOOK AT THAT.
>> IF YOU'RE DOING
A SHOOT LIKE THIS,
WHERE YOUR FACE IS BEING COVERED
WITH, SAY, A BEARD
OR SOMETHING TO TAKE AWAY
A PART OF YOUR BEAUTY,
IT RELIES ON
THE REST OF YOUR LOOK
TO REALLY MAKE UP FOR IT.
DON'T LOSE FAITH.
JUST KEEP IT UP AND PRACTICE.
>> I THINK
THAT PICTURE'S A MESS.
>> PERSONALLY FOR ME,
I DON'T THINK IT'S A MESS.
>> YOU CAN USE
WHAT YOU'RE FEELING
IN YOUR PHOTO...
>> MM-HMM.
>> SO IF YOU'RE
FEELING INSECURE--
YOU'RE THE BEARDED LADY,
AND THE BEARDED LADY
IN THE CIRCUS PROBABLY
DOESN'T WANNA BE THERE,
SO YOU PUT THAT INTO HER STORY,
AND YOU GIVE HER
EVERY SINGLE THING
THAT YOU'RE FEELING.
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, MEGG.
ALL RIGHT, CARIDEE, SO YOU HAD
A FREAK SHOW PHOTO SHOOT.
BY THE WAY, YOU LOOK VERY CHIC.
>> AH!
>> AND WHAT FREAK WERE YOU?
>> I WAS
MISS ELEPHANT TRUNK NOSE.
>> FANTASTIC.
>> YEAH.
>> WELL, LET'S SEE YOUR BEST
ELEPHANT TRUNK NOSE SHOT.
>> WOW.
>> WOW! OH, THAT ROCKS.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU ARE
STRADDLING THAT CAR.
>> LOOK AT HER BODY.
IT'S AMAZING.
>> THAT'S A GREAT SHOT.
>> WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THIS
IS THE FACT THAT
YOU HAVEN'T ALLOWED THE FACT
YOU HAVE AN ELEPHANT NOSE
INHIBIT YOU AT ALL.
>> IT WAS REALLY HARD.
I HAD A HUGE HAT AND NOSE
AND AN UMBRELLA.
>> YOU'RE MODELING THROUGH
THE NOSE. I LOVE IT.
>> BY THE END OF THIS SHOT,
I WANTED AN ELEPHANT NOSE.
I'M TELLING YOU.
>> REALLY?
>> BUT ONE THING, CARIDEE,
IS I WOULD'VE LIKED TO SEE
YOUR FACE CATCH THE LIGHT MORE.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU SEE HOW THE LIGHT'S
ALL OVER YOUR BODY?
I'M ALMOST LOSING THE NOSE...
>> YEAH.
>> AND THE NOSE IS REALLY
WHAT THE SHOT IS ABOUT.
SO WELL DONE.
(imitates elephant trumpeting)
PFFT.
>> (laughter)
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, CARIDEE.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE ABOUT ALL OF THESE
CIRCUS FREAK GIRLS,
AND AFTER WE DELIBERATE,
I'LL CALL YOU BACK
AND ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪
>> ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT IS TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH GIRL IS GOING HOME.
WHICH FREAK?
>> (laughter)
>> MELROSE.
>> I LOVE THE PHOTO.
>> I THINK THIS WAS ONE
OF THE HARDEST CHALLENGES,
TO HAVE AN OLD FACE.
IT'S STILL A FASHION PHOTOGRAPH.
>> I ACTUALLY ASSIGNED MELROSE
TO HAVE THE OLD FACE
BECAUSE I FELT THAT
SHE COULD HANDLE IT.
BROOKE.
>> BROOKE IS LIKE
A "SEVENTEEN" READER.
THERE'S SOMETHING
SO SWEET ABOUT HER.
YOU JUST WANNA
PUT HER ON A CUPCAKE.
>> I STILL HAVEN'T SEEN
A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH OF HER FACE.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
SHE IS CAPABLE OF THAT.
>> EUGENA.
>> (imitates bird squawking)
>> HUNGRY, CHICKEE?
>> I FELT,
FOR THE BULK OF THE SHOOT,
SHE WAS PRETTY DEAD IN HER EYES.
>> THIS IS--THIS COULD JUST
BE A LUCKY SHOT THEN.
>> A.J.
>> ANY GIRL THAT COULD
EAT A MAN UP LIKE THIS,
I LOVE HER.
A.J.'s IN.
>> I THINK A.J.'s REALLY MANAGED
TO BRING THE MODEL
TO THIS PICTURE,
PROBABLY THE ONLY GIRL
THAT'S REALLY GOT
THE FULL FASHION IDEA
IN THIS OLD TIMEY KIND OF SHOT.
>> MEGG.
>> OH, GOSH, MEGG.
I-I THINK THIS PICTURE
IS DISASTROUS.
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
HER UNSTABLENESS THAT REALLY--
IT'S QUITE SCARY.
>> I WANT TO STICK UP FOR MEGG!
I LIKED HER.
I FELT LIKE SHE WAS
THE KIND OF GIRL
WHO WOULD SELL COPIES
OF "SEVENTEEN."
>> I MEAN, THE PERSONALITY
IS ONE THING--AND, YES,
THE PERSONALITY'S APPEALING.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU CAN'T
TAKE A GOOD PICTURE--
AND SHE HASN'T MANAGED
TO TAKE A GOOD PICTURE--
YOU KNOW, THEN--THEN WHAT IS IT?
>> I SAY MEGG'S USED TO...
(imitates Megg) ROCK 'N' ROLL!
>> AMANDA AND MICHELLE--
JUDGE THEM SEPARATELY.
>> MICHELLE, I THINK,
HAS GOT THE BETTER ANGLES,
AND SHE'S HIDING
AND JUST PUSHING HER BODY
JUST THAT LITTLE BIT MORE.
>> I THINK AMANDA'S
GOT THAT QUIRKINESS
THAT I LIKE IN A MODEL.
>> ANCHAL.
>> ANCHAL, TO ME,
IS A VERY, VERY BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S A MODEL.
HER PERSONALITY BORES ME STIFF.
>> ANCHAL JUST TURNED IN
A BEAUTIFUL PICTURE
BECAUSE SHE'S A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
>> CARIDEE.
>> FOR ME, THIS IS
THE BEST SHOT OF THE GROUP.
>> CARIDEE REALLY
JUST SORT OF OWNED THIS TRUNK.
IT--IT WAS ONE AMAZING POSE
AFTER ANOTHER WITH HER.
>> I LIKE THIS CARIDEE GIRL.
I FEEL LIKE SHE WANTS THIS,
BUT SHE DOESN'T
LOSE WHO SHE IS IN THE PROCESS
OF WANTING IT SO MUCH.
JAEDA.
>> I'M REALLY DOWN ON JAEDA.
WE HAD TO KEEP PUSHING HER
AND PUSHING HER.
IT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU'RE A MODEL.
YOU'RE BOOKED FOR A JOB.
DO YOUR JOB.
>> THERE'S NO ENERGY.
THERE'S NO STRENGTH BEHIND
HER BEING THE STRONG WOMAN.
>> WELL, JAEDA, FOR ME,
I ACTUALLY FIND HER
SOMETIMES TOO MASCULINE.
I ACTUALLY THINK
HER ABS ARE A BIT SCARY.
>> THEY'RE DRAWN.
>> OH, THEY'RE DRAWN!
>> (high-pitched voice) OH, MY!
>> OH, MY GOODNESS! THANK GOD!
I WAS REALLY WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
>> (British accent) OH, TWIGLET!
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS HER.
♪♪
>> TEN BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY,
ONE OF YOU HAS TO GO HOME.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL
IS...
CARIDEE.
>> YEE-HA!
>> GIVE ME AN ELEPHANT SOUND.
>> (imitates
elephant trumpeting)
>> (laughter)
>> WORK IT OUT.
>> (imitates trumpeting)
>> (laughs)
>> CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL...
EUGENA.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
A.J.
(snarls)
CONGRATULATIONS, A.J.,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
CARNIVOROUS MODEL.
>> (laughter)
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME...
(imitates elderly woman)
MELROSE, GET YOUR BUTT
UP HERE, GIRL!
(normal voice) MICHELLE.
THE NEXT NAME...
ANCHAL.
>> OH, FEE-FIE-FO-FUM.
THANK GOD.
>> (laughter)
>> CONGRATULATIONS...
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL IS...
AMANDA.
THE NEXT NAME...
BROOKE.
>> OH!
ALL RIGHTY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL JAEDA AND MEGG
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL STILL
BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
THE JUDGES LOOK AT BOTH OF YOU
AS HAVING SO MUCH POTENTIAL.
MEGG, YOU'RE THIS GIRL
WITH THIS BUBBLY
"ROCK ON!" PERSONALITY,
AND WE SEE SUCH A MAGIC IN YOU
THAT FOR SOME REASON
IS NOT TRANSLATING
INTO YOUR PICTURES.
AND, JAEDA, PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST TRANSFORMATION--
FROM YOUR LONG HAIR
TO YOUR SHORT HAIR,
FROM FEELING LIKE
THE PRETTIEST GIRL IN SCHOOL
TO FEELING LIKE,
"OOH, I'M NOT SO SURE HOW I FEEL
WHEN I LOOK IN THE MIRROR
IN THE MORNING."
BOTH OF YOU GUYS, IT'S LIKE...
YOU'VE GOT THE GOODS,
BUT YOU'RE NOT
BRINGING IT TO THE TABLE.
>> SO, JAEDA,
YOU'RE GONNA GET ANOTHER CHANCE.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR THIS WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY.
(crying)
I'M SORRY, GUYS.
I'M REALLY...
(sniffles) GONNA TAKE THIS
AS JUST ONE OF THOSE THINGS
TO MAKE ME STRONGER.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO HEAR.
COME GIVE ME A HUG.
>> THANK YOU.
ALL THE GIRLS--
I MEAN, A.J., CARIDEE
AND ALL THE REST OF THEM--
I WAS JUST LIKE,
OH, MY GOD, LIKE,
I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO HANG OUT WITH THEM ANYMORE,
LIKE...
(sniffles) YOU KNOW?
IT WAS REALLY HARD
SAYING GOOD-BYE.
I'M GONNA MISS THEM TO DEATH.
BUT, LIKE, I'M PLANNING ON,
YOU KNOW, ME AND MY FRIEND,
WE'RE GONNA START, LIKE,
A 2-PERSON BAND.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
WELL, I'LL BE, LIKE,
A MUSICIAN-MODEL,
AND WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS, MAN.
LIKE, I DIDN'T MAKE IT SO FAR...
YOU KNOW,
EVEN THOUGH I DIDN'T WIN,
I FEEL LIKE I WON
THE EXPERIENCE OF THIS ALL,
AND THAT'S GOOD ENOUGH FOR ME.
(chuckles)
♪♪